[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEVIN NILSON: everyone.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Kevin Nilson, and
I lead the Technical Solutions
Engineering team
for Google Cast.
And today what I'm going
to do is talk to you
about some of the latest
features for Google Cast.
But before I do that,
I know that there's
some of you who are
watching who may not
be familiar with Google
Cast, so I want to give
a really quick overview.
So Google Cast is made up
of senders and receivers.
And what senders are is your
mobile phone, such as Android,
iOS, or a Chrome browser.
And that controls
the video playback.
And then the video
playback is done, actually,
in an HTML5 receiver.
And that runs often in
something like a Chromecast,
or a Chromecast Ultra,
Chromecast Audio,
or even a Google Home.
And so let's look at how
that interaction behaves
and how it happens.
And so you see here
in this illustration
that someone is watching
video playback on their phone.
And they're watching that
playback, but they look up
and they see the big screen.
And they think, I'd like to see
that up on that bigger screen.
And so what they do is they
go down to their phone,
they click the Cast icon,
and that casts the video up
to their television.
At that point, their sender--
or phone or sender--
becomes a remote
control and lets
them control video playback.
Now I want to talk about the
Cast application framework.
So the Cast
application framework
is a framework that has a
lot of great advantages.
And really, what we've
gone out and tried to do
is to create a framework that
is really built from the ground
up around building a
simple media application
experience for developers.
We wanted to build something
that's more reliable
and has UI widgets
out of the box
so that when you go to
build a Cast application
framework and a
Cast integration,
you write a whole lot less code.
Last year at Google I/O right
here at Shoreline Amphitheater,
we actually launched the
Cast application framework
for iOS and Android.
And then later in
the fall, we launched
that for the Chrome web sender.
And what I'm excited
today to announce
is that we are launching the
Cast application framework
receiver very, very soon.
And I'm going to
give you a sneak peak
and show you a
bunch of the code.
And we actually had a
lot of our top developers
that came into Mountain
View, down to Google Campus,
earlier this week, and
we gave a hands-on lab
for those developers where
they could get a sneak peek,
try it out.
But most importantly, so that we
could gather a lot of feedback
from them so that we
know when we launch this,
it's ready and better than ever.
And one of the real advantages,
or one of the real things
that we're trying to do with the
new Cast application framework
receiver is make sure
that it's voice ready.
So as I mentioned last year, we
launched the Cast application
framework for Android,
iOS, and the web sender.
And this is just a highlight
of some of the partners
who've gone out there
and done that migration.
And for them, they've got
a lot of great feedback
from their users.
Their users have really
loved the experience, where
it's gone, and
specifically, I do
want to call out that folks have
found their applications to be
much more reliable.
Now I want to share with you
a simple showcase from one
of our top partners listed
on the previous slide.
And this is about
two months of data.
And so if you kind of watch
that green line go across,
you can see that playback
was very constant.
And then all of a sudden,
when they migrated
to the Cast application
framework, playback increased
dramatically.
And so we really
wanted to look and see
what caused that,
what was the reason?
And so we started overlaying
other data on top to try
to see what else changed.
And what we saw was
that connections
greatly disconnected.
And you think about that, that
doesn't really make sense.
Why would connections decrease
when playback increases?
And what we realized, after
digging a little bit deeper,
is that basically, what was
happening is reconnection
was failing due to code that
was in there previously.
And so with the Cast
application framework,
we really want to handle
reconnection logic out
of the box for all of you
to make it much easier
and give a much
better experience.
Now we'll talk about integration
with the Google Assistant
and voice.
Many of you will remember
from last year at Google I/O
where we announced
the Google Home.
And what's really nice
about the Google Home,
it brings the far-field
mic into your home, often
into your living room, where
you can ask it questions,
do a lot of interesting things.
And then obviously, control
video and audio playback
in your living room or
other places of your home.
And one of the really nice parts
for a Google Cast developer
is that Google Home is
also a Cast receiver.
So all the code that you wrote
to integrate with Chromecast,
or Chromecast Audio,
or Chromecast Ultra
is also the exact same
code to make your app
work on Google Home.
So as I began using Google
Home with my family, one
of the things that
I really realized
for myself is that
there is nothing
more natural than voice.
And it's been very eye-opening.
These are my two youngest boys.
And seeing them even leverage
their voice to control things
in my home has been
absolutely amazing.
And I want to share with you a
story from about a month ago.
I took my family to Disneyland
and we did a long drive,
drove down to LA.
And when we got to our
hotel down in Santa Monica,
the boys quickly held
each other's hands
and ran throughout the
hotel, trying to turn things
on with their voice, sort of
imitating what they've seen
their father do so many times.
And it became so apparent to
me that this next generation,
when they look at
the world, they
think about doing that
control with their voice.
Turning on the light switch
never occurred to them.
It's so natural.
And I think for you, this
is the opportunity for you
to go out there and start
voice enabling your media
applications right away
so you're ready for that.
Many of you will
remember from the Keynote
just yesterday some of
the really awesome things
that we showed of integrating
speaking to the Google Home
and showing additional
data on the TV.
So here's an example
that Rishi had shown.
And you can see
down at the bottom
the chips that are suggesting
additional ways you
can filter that data.
And it really brings
the assistant together
with the Chromecast
and the Google Home
and gives a great
experience for the users.
Now I want to go ahead and talk
about the new Cast application
framework receiver that
I'm announcing here
at Google I/O.
And that receiver,
we want it to be
significantly more reliable
and voice ready out of the box.
And with that receiver,
what we're hoping is
it has all the same
advantages that you
saw with the other parts of
the Cast application framework.
And that is having UI widgets
built out of the box and ready,
control for voice
out of the box,
and a much more reliable
experience where developers
are writing
significantly less code
to get that great experience.
So here's a list of some
of the things that you
can do, one of those being
voice control, such as asking,
what's playing on my TV?
So to do that with the new Cast
application framework receiver,
you actually don't have
to write any code at all.
You get that.
You get that out of the
box with the new receiver.
You're also able to
do things like turning
on and off captions,
changing audio tracks,
or controlling the experience,
such as pausing, resuming,
or seeking.
The new receiver also has
a lot of improvements.
And we already mentioned
the voice interactions.
There's also a whole
list of other things
that you can see here.
But most importantly,
you're going
to write a whole lot less
code and get more features out
of the box.
And really, what
we wanted to do is
one of the main
underlying principles
was take our media
player and integrate that
into the receiver
for the API surface
so that you had a
single API surface that
was much simpler than
dealing with them separately.
So now let's jump into the code.
So the code that we have
here is the simplest code
to create a receiver
application.
And what you'll do is start
by creating a custom element
adding the Cast media player.
And then from there, you'll
add one JavaScript library,
the Cast framework JS.
And then you're going
to grab an instance
of the CastReceiverContext
and call start.
And so that's all the
code you have to write.
This receiver will work, it'll
play, it'll pause, it'll scrub,
it'll have voice
control ready for you.
But a lot of people need
some additional custom logic
in their application.
So here's an example
of how do you
deal with loading a different
stream on your receiver
than what you have in
your mobile phone, which
is a very common use case,
because a lot of people
will use a 4k case
stream on Chromecast,
while on their
phone they're going
to use a much lighter weight
stream with a lower resolution.
And so what we've
introduced to make
this possible, following
AOP principles,
would be a message interceptor.
And so you can see here I've got
the player, created a message
interceptor, and
then basically, I'm
intercepting the load request.
And load is basically
the play command.
And inside of the
load request, I'm
going to go ahead and
I have a private API
that I've written where am I to
go out and fetch those assets,
and figure out from the ID, what
URL do I actually want to play?
And then you can see here,
I'm able to use a promise.
And when the promise
completes, then I'll
set the-- when I
get my response,
I'll go ahead and set my
contents ID and then return it.
And that's all you need to do.
Now I want to talk
about, well, what
happened if the
API call had failed
and you do have a failure?
So here I've got a
verifyCredentials
call that I made when
the load request came in.
And then you can
see in the catch,
I set the error type
to load failure.
And I'm setting the error reason
to authentication expired.
And so you definitely
want to make sure
that you're handling
these errors.
And it's very simple to do
that within the promise.
Another thing that we've created
is a playback config object.
And really, what
we're trying to do
is to create a single
object that holds
all of your configuration.
Because previously,
you had to go
throughout the code
in various places
and add all this configuration.
We wanted to be able to
read these properties
from a single location.
And so you can see
some examples here,
such as setting the
initial bandwidth.
So you can see here,
I set it to 2 megabit
for the adaptive bit rate.
Setting which license
server that you're going
to use with the license URL.
And then whether or not
you're passing credentials
with each manifest request that
go across with the headers,
the HTTP headers.
Another thing that we added was
a simple single line of code
that allows you to get
access to both text
tracks and audio tracks.
And those of you who've worked
with Cast SDK in the past
know that previously,
this took a lot of code.
It was a lot of code.
And this is just one
example of an area where
we looked at what optimizations
can we make for common use
cases that developers
are doing to make
it really simple with the Cast
application framework receiver.
There at the bottom, you can
see a single line of code
that allows you to look
up tracks by language.
And so where this is really
important is when you're
integrating with
voice and someone
asks, show the closed captions
in Spanish, for example.
Here you have just a
single line of code
that will let you
look up all available
tracks in Spanish, or in
English here in this example.
Now, I want to talk about
our eventing framework
that we've added.
And so one example of eventing
where you may want to use this
would be to handle analytics.
So what we've tried to
do is make it possible
for you to put
all your analytics
in its own file
rather than scattered
throughout all of your logic.
And so you can see here
on the playerManager,
I've added an event listener
to listen to all events.
And so at any event, no
matter what type it is,
I send that off to my analytic
server, such as Google
Analytics, Firebase Analytics.
And then at the bottom, you'll
see I've done the same thing,
but only subscribing
to playback events.
And so when I get
a playback event,
you can see at the
bottom where I'm
able to pull out the media
time where that event happened.
So then I can ask questions
like, for example,
if we find often that we're
having some sort of a buffering
event happening
early in our video,
then we may want to adjust
our initial adaptive bit rate
settings so that we're
taking a lower bit rate,
so that we don't have to
deal with so much buffering
for our users.
Another feature that
we've added is the ability
to do UI binding.
So if you want to go crazy
and build a UI that's
a lot different than what
we give you out of the box
and the UI controls that we
provide, here's an example.
It's a bit of a sneak peek.
We're still working on
the APIs, but it will look
something very similar to this.
And this is some
code that at the top
we're doing a bunch
of setup for Angular.
I'm sure many of you are
familiar with Angular.
And then basically,
what we're doing
is binding the player
to the player's data.
And then at the bottom, you can
see a handlebar mustache type
syntax where we're actually--
every time the current time
changes or the duration
changes, those are bound
with a single line of code.
Lastly, one of the things
that many of you'd want to do
is style or theme things.
And so you can remember you
added the Cast media player--
it's a single custom element--
to your page.
And then what you'd like to
do is be able to theme it.
And so you can see here
where I set a theme hue.
And so that's a single
value there of blue.
Or in this example, I
go from yellow to green.
And then also able to set the
URL for my logo and splash
images and things like that.
Now I want to change gears
and talk about the web sender.
The web sender
launched last fall.
It's available for all
of you to use today.
And I want to go ahead and show
you some of the basic concepts
there.
And before I really
dive into the code,
I want to talk about some of the
changes we've made in Chrome.
So one of the things
we've done in Chrome
is we've made a tighter
integration with Cast.
So now you're able to
actually right-click and cast
a piece of content.
Previously, to use Cast
within the Chrome browser,
users had to install
a Chrome extension.
And that Chrome
extension would give you
the Cast icon up in the top of
the browser, like you see here.
What has changed for
Chrome is that there
are many users, or
new users, who may not
have that Chrome extension.
So a tip for all of
you, do make sure
that you add a Cast icon
to all of your pages
that have a player.
And so an example
here, you can see
in the player in the
middle on the right
where we've got the Cast icon
right there on the player,
because otherwise, it would be
a hidden feature that would only
be found by right-clicking.
Now I want to talk
about the code to do it.
So let's start on the bottom
on this one, a little bit
different.
So you can see
I've added a button
and I've set it is
of type cast button.
And then just above that, I'm
loading the cast_sender.js,
and I'm passing a
single parameter of load
the CastApplicationFramework.
And that basically
tells us that you're
doing this with a Cast
application framework
rather than our
legacy web sender.
And then at the top, we're
going to add a window list--
bind a function to the
window so that basically, you
can know whether or not
you're running on Chrome.
And if you are running on
Chrome, then you have Cast.
And then we're going to go
ahead and set your application
ID so we know which
app to run when
someone clicks the Cast icon.
Now let's talk about
media playback.
So when the user wants
to go ahead and play
a piece of media in the Cast
application framework web
sender.
What we do is go ahead
and get an instance
of the Cast context,
get the current session,
and have that ready so that
we have a Cast session.
Then we're going to go ahead
and create a media information
object.
And this is a domain object that
represents a piece of media.
We'll create a load request.
And load is basically play.
We'll create that load request,
give it the media information
object, and then call loadMedia.
Within the loadMedia,
when it succeeds--
you want to wait for that load
to succeed before you go ahead
and call playOrPause--
what we're going to need to do
is create a new RemotePlayer.
And then pass the
RemotePlayerController
that player and
call playOrPause.
So it's pretty simple
to get a web sender up
and running, quite a
bit simpler and easier
than what we've done before.
Styling also very
similar, where here you
can see we style everything
with the ID of castButton.
And if you look at
the bottom where
we added the ID of
castButton, and then
here we're able to set
the connected color
to green and the
disconnected color to white.
Now I want to talk about
some of the updates
that we've made on
the mobile senders
for the Cast
application framework.
And that would be
both Android and iOS.
So let's start with some of the
Android stuff that we've done.
So these are a list of
many of the improvements
across the mobile senders.
So one of the first things
that we did in Android
was really provide
detailed documentation
on how to style the UI
widgets that are provided.
Because what we want
to do is provide
a widget that has all the
functionality and all the code
to work.
And even though you didn't
write all that code,
it looks exactly like
the rest of your app
and is able to be
styled and themed.
And so as the year went on,
we implemented and documented
how to do this so that you can
make these experiences look
amazing for your users.
Another thing that we
added was the ability
to configure what buttons show
up in your mini controller.
So if you look down on the
bottom, you can see on the left
that we have just one button,
a play or pause button.
But if you would
like to customize
it to be able to rewind
backwards or forward,
and add those buttons,
all you need to do
is add a single array
in your resource--
add an array in
your resource that
specifies the buttons
you would like
to have in your mini player.
And it looks exactly
the same if you'd
like to configure the
buttons within your expanded
controller or your full
screen casting experience.
Now I want to talk
about styling on iOS.
So iOS is a little
bit different,
because we don't have all
the power like you'd have
with styles, XML, and Android.
So we had to build
something programmatic
to have the same
kind of features.
And really, what we
were trying to do
is achieve something that
had a cascading effect
so you didn't have to
write that much code
to apply the same
theme in several places
within your application.
And so let's go ahead and
walk through the code.
So I'm getting a shared
instance of the GCK UI style.
And then what I'm
doing is walking
from the Cast views to the media
control to the mini controller
and setting its body
text to be read.
So that's a very specific
command, a very specific piece
that I'd like to change.
And then if you look
at the next line,
I'm setting all Cast views
background color to be blue.
So you have the
flexibility to determine
if you want things to control
broadly across all the views
or just across specific ones.
And you can see down at
the bottom, the breakdown
where we breakdown between the
instructions, device control,
media control, and all
the different screens.
Now I want to give you a sneak
peek of some of the things
that are coming really soon for
the Cast application framework
receiver.
And I want to talk about ads.
So ads will come
very soon, but it'll
come after we release
that public beta.
And after we finally release
the Cast application framework
receiver, we'll bring
in the support for ads.
But I want to give you
a sneak peek today.
So one of the things
that we've always
done when working with ads,
and our users have had to do,
our developers
have had to do, is
provide a lot of custom fields.
So we didn't have structure
around the data that
represented an ad.
And so the problem
that we had without
having structure
around that data is it
made it impossible for us,
within the mobile centers,
to know how to react
when you're within an ad,
because there was no structure.
And so what we've
done to address that
is introduce this
notion of break clips.
Those are the media that's
going to be played for your ad,
and their duration.
And then define where
those breaks happen
within your piece of content.
And what this does
really gives us
that structure that lets us
say, when you enter an ad,
let's disable skipping so
users can't scrub out of ads
or skip past them, which is
an experience that most of us
want in our applications
so we can monetize well.
So the example I'm
showing here shows
how to pass that
information from the sender.
But for most applications, you'd
like to do it on the receiver.
So let's show how to control
that from the receiver.
So we're going to use
an interceptor again
and we're going to
intercept that load request.
Some when a reload
request comes into play
a piece of media,
what we're going to do
is we're going to go ahead
and call out to an API
with a promise to fetch our ads.
Once we get those ads back,
then we can set the break clips
and define where
those breaks occur.
That's all you have to do.
It's very, very convenient
so that basically you
can change those ads on
the fly from the receiver.
Because often, you want to
control that from the receiver
and you want to control that
as each piece of media loads.
Now I want to talk
about queuing.
So in the Cast
application framework,
two years ago at
I/O, we actually
launched a queuing API.
And what we found was it
was difficult for developers
to use.
And So.
What we wanted to do was to
create a new queuing mechanism
that really started from
the fundamental thinking
that your application has a
queue when you're not casting.
And so you have
existing APIs, probably
some form of a cloud queue.
And we wanted to be able to
integrate with that cloud queue
so that you can have an
experience that as users went
in and out of casting,
it continued to work,
and made it really,
really easy for you.
So here's a quick example.
And you can see the
way that it does
is we start by having you extend
a base class of QueueBase.
And then from there, you can
override a lot of methods.
So here, for example,
is the load method.
So I've overrode
the load method.
Actually go out there
and fetch my data.
So this is where I'm
calling out to my cloud,
asking what items are in
this playlist, for example.
So if someone asks for
a load for a playlist,
you're going to go ahead and
look up, what are the songs
or what are the videos within
that particular playback.
You can set things
like, where would I
like to start
within that playback
and what time stamp would
I like them to start.
And So.
This is a bit of a sneak peek.
The code may change
a little bit,
but this is really what we're
starting to work on today
and gathering feedback from
a lot of our top developers
and partners as to what
they'd like to see.
So if you do have any thoughts,
we'd love to hear them.
Please come and
see me afterwards
and we'd love to
hear from all of you.
Next I want to talk about Live.
And this is what
we're going to do
after we launch the Cast
application framework receiver.
What we have found as
we reviewed several
of our top apps who
deal with Live is we
found that Live is a little bit
different for every single app.
Maybe not every app, but
there's several ways to do it.
And so what we didn't
want to do is put together
something that's too
simplistic that doesn't
give our developers the
power to have a turnkey
experience for handling Live.
And so we've been
collecting data
from a lot of different
partners and developers
and looking at this.
And what we want to do is to
provide an implementation that
gives you the flexibility to
define how Live works for you.
Some apps you can pause
and have a DVR window.
Some apps you can scrub.
Others you can't.
Others have sliding
windows of where
you can rewind back throughout.
Some of them, from the start
of an event, you can scroll.
And so these are
just some examples
of some of this complex logic.
And we want to try
to build something
that lets you do all of
that, and make it really,
really simple.
So this is what we're looking
at doing later in the year
as we move forward.
And so I'm really
excited to see that
happen because I know it's going
to help a lot of developers.
The last thing I
want to talk to you
about is the Chromecast
Preview Program.
And what this is is
it's the ability for you
to test your code against our
newest or unreleased software.
And so when we think
it's ready to ship
and we think we're ready to push
platform changes out to users,
we push it out to devices that
are on the Chromecast Preview
Program.
And so it's a great
opportunity for you
to register some devices in
your test lab against this,
add them to this program,
so that you can make sure
that your application
isn't going
to break when we push that out.
Another great advantage
that you'll get
is we have thousands
of devices that
are registered as part of the
Chromecast Preview Program.
And so we've got thousands
of developers and thousands
of just regular users
out there using your app
against the preview program.
So even if you
don't find problems,
other users out in the
field have the opportunity
to find those and
report those as well.
So I highly encourage all of
you to go try this out and start
using it as part of your QA
regression test and making sure
that your app is as
good as it can be.
And with that, what I
want to do is tell you
about a few resources that you
have where you can learn more.
The first is
developer.google.com/cast.
You can find all of our
documentation and our samples
out there.
Next is Stack Overflow.
So on Stack
Overflow, we actually
have a team of people
who are actually
answering questions and
making sure the right
and best questions
are available.
So do look in Stack Overflow.
We highly encourage it, and
we have a team of people
out there working on that.
Next is the G+
Developer Community.
This is a great place
to see announcements.
So for example, when we
launch the beta for the Cast
application framework
receiver shortly,
we'll post a message on Google+
so that that's available
and you're aware of it.
So you can go and try it out
and give us that feedback.
And finally, out on YouTube
with Google Developers,
you can see a lot
of great videos,
both on Cast and all the other
things that you learned here
at Google I/O. And with that,
I want to thank all of you
for coming.
And happy casting.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]